yossi go/s doué champion de france de
semi-marathon 2015 est arrivé en
touraine il y a deux ans son terrain de
jeu favori lille 6 mo avec 9 à 13 heures
d'entraînement par semaine ils y passent
forcément un peu de temps aux athlètes
de haut niveau il a également monté une
structure pour accompagner les amoureux
de la course à pied vers leurs
différents objectifs
ils sont en forme ça va ce que vous
couriez 10 va ou 42 km salle simple on
dise pas ce qu'ils veulent bien figurer
à tous en septembre ont commencé le
travail dès le mois de juin avec 6 et
ses amis entraîneur travailler dans la
douleur certes mais avec le sourire
toujours le problème c'est aussi nous
aussi on est un peu en retard sur notre
préparation va directement vouloir faire
des séances assez dur et exigeant et en
même temps on n'aura pas le physique
pour et donc du coup ne prendra pas
plaisir donc au contraire c'est d'y
aller tranquillement pour qu'une fois
qu'ils allaient séance plus difficile
des sorties de deux heures et voilà qui
fera d'eux des appelés celle ci bas en
plus les organiser en fin de compte avec
un passif et parce que trop bon ben
voilà on prend pas plaisir et avec
certains comme gilles cela va même au
delà de la préparation et aussi
l'accompagner dans un marathon à prague
au printemps les deux hommes continuent
à travailler ensemble en vue de celui de
porto en novembre l'aventuré sportive et
humaine
il ya la bonne humeur vraiment c'est
extrêmement important et puis le fait
qu'il soit très pédagogue donc du coup
donne du sens aux choses et c'est super
important quand on court on commence à
avoir un petit peu mal qu'on a les
jambes qui pique
c'est bien de savoir pourquoi on le fait
c'est bien d'avoir compris pourquoi on
le faisait et ça c'est extrêmement
attentifs avant porto au passage
incontournable par tour le 23 septembre
les 20 km font partie du programme
d'entraînement un beau basket si vous
voulez être au coeur de la fête vous
aussi et pour ceux qui n'aiment pas
courir sachez que l'organisation
recherche des bénévoles